mais d'abord ce que change ou pas la
candidature de christiane taubira avec
sagna de chiens
son nom vient désormais s'ajouter à la
longue liste des candidats de gauche à
la présidentielle
si elle remporte la primaire populaire
christiane taubira se lancera bien dans
la course l'ancien ministre de la
justice de françois hollande l'annoncé
ce week end à lyon je suis candidate à
la présidence
la socialiste anne hidalgo en
déplacement à quelques kilomètres à
vaulx en velin à jouer l'indifférence l
annonce de cette nouvelle adversaires
chacun est libre de ce qu'ils entendent
et maintenant projet contre projet
contrairement à christiane taubira anne
hidalgo ne participera pas à la primaire
populaire organisé fin janvier pour
choisir un candidat commun à la gauche
pas plus que les autres candidats en
meeting à nantes jean luc mélenchon l'a
balayé d'un revers de main vous ne
pouvez pas mobilisés si vous donnez
l'impression vous êtes un menteur qui va
ensuite à ranger ses carabistouilles
dans un coin avec ses copains des autres
partis je ne fus pas leurs copains pas
question non plus pour yannick jadot de
se plier aux résultats de ce vote
citoyen en ligne il légitime à ses yeux
moi ce que je fais en cette campagne
c'est la guerre pour le climat
c'est pas la guéguerre avec la vieille
gauche ou au sein de la vieille gauche
plus divisé que jamais la gauche compte
désormais six prétendants presque tous à
moins de 10 % dans les sondages à
l'exception de jean luc mélenchon seul
arnaud montebourg créditées de 1% des
intentions de vote envisagerait de
renoncer à sa candidature dans les
prochains jours
et on analyse
les événements de ce week-end côté
gauche dans ce débat avec mes invités
catherine tricot bonsoir vous êtes la
directrice de la revue regards vous
publiez la gauche grand remplacer voilà
c'est le dernier numéro de la revue
regards comment en est on arrivé là bon
titre je suis un peu jaloux j'aurais pu
y penser jean-daniel les hiboux reçoit
bienvenue vous êtes le directeur délégué
de harris interactive mathieu souquet
rebond soir experts associés à la
formation jorge lorenzo publié 2022 la
flambée populiste c'est chez plon
matthieu croissandeau bonsoir il chante
en lice politique à mes côtés tous les
lundis et mercredis dans ce sens public
et puis on sera tout à l'heure en duplex
avec samuel grzybowski qu'est le
porte-parole et co-fondateur de la
primaire populaire alors on parlera
aussi du meeting de jean luc mélenchon
de l'avenir dé gauche aux législatives
parce qu'il faut se projeter un peu
après mais d'abord catherine tricot
cette candidature de christiane taubira
elle vous inspire quelle réaction
qu'elle analyse pas le premier adjectif
qui vous qui vous vient à l'esprit
perplexe oui parce que quand même elle
avait annoncé qu'elle voulait se
présenter pour rassembler les gauche
elle n'a pas eu de succès et se
maintient elle se présente quand même
alors on se dit pas ça ne fait qu'une
candidature de plus on ne voit pas du
tout en quoi cette candidature apporte
quelque chose de nouveau au débat et en
quoi elle serait capable de surmonter la
division des gauches donc là on s'est
quand même vraiment très troublant cette
histoire
deux candidatures alors il se dit en
tout cas on a interrogé aujourd'hui le
patron du prg sur le site de regard qui
nous dit qu'ils pensent encore pouvoir
faire bouger les lignes qu'ils espèrent
avec les 250 mille citoyens qui vont
participer à la primaire citoyenne
pouvoir faire pression sur les autres
partis donc il pense encore pouvoir
faire bouger anne hidalgo et yannick
jadot bon je sais pas ça je pense qu'on
peut toujours y croire moi j'ai
l'impression que maintenant chacun est
engagée sur sa sur sa ligne et que
christiane taubira ne montre pas dans
les sondages
un élan autour d'elle vous allez nous le
dira mais elle ne semble pas pouvoir
bouger sa candidature ne sont pas
pouvoir faire bouger les lignes à ce
stade effectivement j'en ai ma vie quand
déjà tiens quand on voit le total gauche
dans votre dernier baromètre pour pour
challenges il est à moins de 27 à 26 et
demi donc c'est vraiment très faible
est-ce que christiane taubira fait
monter ce score est ce qu'elle vient
s'ajouter ou est-ce qu'elle picore un
peu à droite à gauche chez les candidats
qui étaient des actes il déclaré quand
je reprends votre terme elle picore
c'est encore un peu un peu du côté de
yannick jadot un peu de côté d'anne
hidalgo un peu de jean luc mélenchon est
en finale voilà elle arrive à tangente
et avec les 4 5% d'intentions de vote ce
qui est faible dans l'absolu et surtout
qui est pas du tout dans ce qui était
imaginé de la part de certains c'est à
dire l'arrivée de christiane taubira qui
créerait une forme des faits blast qu'on
l'a dit par le passé c'est à dire
qu'elle récupèrerait au fait de sa
notoriété de son image toute une partie
d'un électorat qui justement appellerait
à l'unité ce qui est assez frappant
c'est qu'à une très forte différence
entre l'opinion qui peut être portée à
l'égard de christiane taubira de la part
des électeurs de gauche et la manière
dont elle peut bénéficier à l'heure
actuelle d'un capital électoral
aujourd'hui christiane taubira c'est une
forme de mentors de la vie politique en
tout cas pour la gauche et celle qui a
porté les valeurs haut et fort c'est
celle qui a osé quitter le gouvernement
de françois hollande sur la question de
la déchéance de la nationalité
sans jamais entrer en conflit direct
avec lui en disant on a des accords
politiques et donc c'est au nom des
valeurs que je vais quitter le
gouvernement quand on sait que ces deux
là dessus que françois hollande c'est
presque le plus abîmé dans le cadre de
son précédent mandat et donc elle la
valeur
se concentra parce qu en fait voilà on a
du mal à savoir aujourd'hui quand on a
un électeur de gauche ce qui est son
projet politique ce que sont ses
principales orientations et même ce que
serait sa compétence à pouvoir gouverner
ou diriger la france parce que ça n'a
jamais fait partie vraiment des points
sur lesquels elle avait mis l'accent par
le passé et puis mathieu foot il faut
faire un peu d'histoire politique ce
n'est sans doute pas la plus
rassembleuse des personnalités de gauche
dans ceux dans ce pays qui servira non
alors c'est pas la plus nouvelle par
ailleurs ça nous renvoie à la
présidentielle de 2002 un mot quand même
sur ce que m'évoque sa déclaration de
candidature où tout est la cause la
forme qu'elle a choisi de donner on
entend sa candidature les images on
voyait les images donc de 50 et ensuite
parler à celle du meeting de jean luc
mélenchon les images compte toujours à
fortiori dans une campagne où les
rendez-vous physiques sont plus en plus
compliqué à organiser c'est assez
étrange le décor qu'elle donne à sa
déclaration de candidature
s'il ya un côté fin du monde sait qu'il
ya un brouillard derrière il ya des tags
autour il ya une espèce de grillage
cétacés n'y a pas convoqué le brouillard
il est alors il fait là ce matin le
brouillard s'est sans doute pas de sa
faute mais mais mais quand même l'image
encore une fois qu'il reste on peut y
voir un symbole premières images on y
voit un symbole de la gauche est
détendue ceci étant dit le meeting jean
luc mélenchon était assez impressionnant
visuellement mais là on le voit
s'exprimer devant des vagues en pleine
vague épidémique c'est assez étonnant
aussi comme symbole le show choisi mais
peu importe mais donc la candidature de
cristiano lien renvoie donc quand même à
l'imaginaire de la présidentielle de
2002 et et le parallèle n'est pas
absurde à faire en 2002 la gauche était
très dispersé également c'est ce qui a
conduit à ce que le point de
qualification soit assez bas et que
contre toute attente le favori de la
présidentielle ne soit même pas au
second tour donc c'était le fameux choc
du 21 avril et donc à l'époque la gauche
étaient divisés parce qu'elle était
forte et parce qu'elles étaient fortes
elles se paient le luxe de se diviser
oui ça suscitait des appétits parce
qu'il y avait un capital gauche on peut
se diviser canton elle est très fort
d'une certaine façon c'est ce que fait
aujourd'hui la droite et l'extrême
droite mais on peut aussi se divise et
quand on est très faible c'est une
tentation existe de façon très forte et
donc aujourd'hui effectivement la gauche
se divise parce qu'elle est faible et
évidemment se divisant elle s'affaiblit
encore davantage mais un point quand
même sur le score cumulé de la gauche
les 25 ou 27 % que vous évoquez à
l'instant en fait c'est à peu près le
score que la gauche a fait en 2017 et
ayant à lorient c'est très bas mais en
2017 avec 1 25% tout y est jean luc
mélenchon était à quelques encablures du
second tour donc en réalité aujourd'hui
à 25 ou 27 % la gauche pourrait si elle
était moins diviser mais être pas très
loin du second tour car on voit bien que
les autres à droite et à l'extrême
droite sont également dans un mouchoir
de poche avec des scores qui ne sont pas
si élevé que cela ce qui change
évidemment c'est que le total des voix
de gauche aujourd'hui même s'il est
équivalent à celui d'il ya cinq ans
c'est avec deux à trois fois plus de
candidats qu'il y a donc ça fait toute
la différence moi je surveille jouant
matthieu croissandeau grâce à des
interventions sur ce plat tout veiller
un peu petit pour quoi d'abord est-ce
qu'on peut parler de la gauche il y
avait un nid d'aigle et gaucheret et
pour reprendre l'exemple que donne et
mathieu sur 2017 une partie des voix de
gauche c'était quand même porté sur un
ancien ministre d'un gouvernement de
gauche nommé emmanuel macron et qui à
l'époque par passer pour une partie de
l'électorat social démocrate comme un
débouché politique de gauche donc le
total gauche était quand même plus élevé
que ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui après
moi je tout à fait d'accord avec mathieu
la gauche était sûr de gagner en 2002
pour ça qu'il s'était permis de se
diviser et chacun en dts diarra ben on
va mettre un petit coup de de trotskisme
un petit coup de verre un petit coup de
chevènement un petit coup voilà pour
essayer de 2,2 feu de faire vivre la
gauche plurielle aujourd'hui elle est
sûre de perdre et d'une certaine façon
ça explique aussi cela la vraie question
qui se pose avec christiane taubira c
est ce qu elle cède au pourquoi pas moi
ou est ce qu'elle veut transformer la
france est est-ce qu'elle a un projet
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que comme
l'a dit un peu cruellement françois
hollande c'est un combat de lilliputiens
et que du coup tous les lits tous les
lilliputiens possible se sentent pousser
des ailes et se disent pourquoi pas moi
je n'ai pas entendu de la bouche de
christiane taubira au delà des quelques
mesures qu'elle a égrainé samedi une
vision de la société un projet de
transformation or la gauche est toujours
gagné quand elle portait un projet de
transformation sociale le seul mantra
qu'on entend chez elle mais aussi chez
d'autres c'est de mettre un terme à ces
cinq années de macron la mettre un terme
ça ne suffit pas toujours ça peu de
temps en temps faire gagner c'est ce
qu'ils avaient gagné ce qu avait servi à
françois hollande en 2012 mais ça ne
suffit pas toujours pour l'emporter et
on revient à ce qu'on a dit plusieurs
fois ce plateau c'est une gauche cas pas
assez travaillé depuis depuis plusieurs
années oui j'aime sur les idées et je
compte là dessus c'est une gauche qui
n'a pas tiré les leçons des deux
précédents scrutins présidentiels elle a
pas elle a surestimé sa responsabilité
en 2012 c'est à dire qu'elle est
persuadée d'avoir gagné sur ses idées
sur son projet or elle a quand même
beaucoup gagner enfin la gagner pour
mettre un terme aux cinq ans de
sarkozysme et elle a sous-estimé d'une
certaine façon sa défaite en 2017
considérant que considérant que si elle
avait perdu c'est parce qu'elle avait
été trahi par emmanuel macron c'est
parce qu'elle était divisée par jean luc
mélenchon il n'y a pas eu ce travail sur
est ce que la gauche répond aujourd'hui
aux enjeux qui se posent dans la société
une question qui se que se posent les
français au quotidien en quoi il ya
toujours une part de supplément d'âme
normalement à gauche une part de
romantisme on va dire elle est là pour
transformer la société un monde meilleur
entre guillemets je ne sais pas du tout
l'apanage de la gauche mais c'est en
tout cas comme ça qu'elle se vend et là
on ne voit pas aujourd'hui
en quoi en quoi ce projet de
transformation de la société existe
quatre entre coridon mais jean-luc
mélenchon quand même a continué son
effort de renouvellement c'est qu'on a
entendu et quand vous disiez la dernière
fois en effet y avait pas d'accord entre
toutes ces gauches qu'ils étaient
relativement nombreux aussi la dernière
fois et jean luc mélenchon avait émergé
sur la propre force de son discours et
de sa proposition politique est en fait
là c'est bien un peu ce qu'ils espèrent
si vous l'avez entendu hier il dit je
suis une tortue saga c'est à dire que je
vais finalement rien ne sert de courir
il faut partir à danger mis en place
tous des jalons je ne me je ne suis pas
concerné par le bazar qui règne à gauche
et moi je trace mon chemin et j'ai
quelque chose à vous raconter il le fait
avec un certain talent donc en fait lui
il a encore l'espoir de renouveler ce
qu'il avait fait en 2010 est à dire
rassemblé une part substantielle de
l'électorat de gauche autour de son
oncle mais d'atteindre comme ça le
second tour qui cette fois ci pourrait
être encore plus bas que la dernière
fois puisque
7% et dresse mélenchon se dit à 16,17 la
place je confirme qu aujourd'hui c'est
le cas on va bouffer d'incertitude
beaucoup d'électeurs qui ont pas choisir
il n'y ait pas l'espoir de monter à
13,17 plus qu'il n'y était précisément
il ya cinq ans absolument mais à 5 ans
des 19 ans il atteint 19% mais on va pas
prendre tout le contenu mais comment
vous vous répondez à la question comment
en est on arrivé là c'est quoi pour vous
l'élément le plus important il ya
certains des arguments qu donné mathieu
non plus important c'est de ne pas avoir
renouvelé la pensée ça ça me paraît
évidente c'est à dire que je partage la
somme des petits renoncements et des
petites trahisons plus pas de pas de
travail ça fait que c'est une gauche qui
alors il ya la partie mélenchon nien qui
elle a mon avis à travailler et à
quelque chose à dire mais est assez peu
rassemblé enfin jean luc mélenchon est
quand même sur une position
je dirais dans l'extrait que vous avez
passé on voit bien qu'il ne tend pas la
main voilà il dit moi je suis droit dans
mes bottes je ne suis pas leurs copains
j'ai ma proposition et j'avance donc à
cette partie là qui à mon avis a quand
même fait le boulot et puis l autre
partie de la gauche puisque la gauche de
la gauche allait jamais unique elle est
toujours double est toujours eu la
tradition socialiste communisme
social-démocrate insoumise enfin peu
importe ça se raconte de plein de
manières mais historiquement la gauche
elle est elle n'est pas unique et donc
le côté radical je pense que mélenchon
l'a investi de manière intelligente mais
assez peu rassembleuse et l'autre côté
baleni intelligente nérini très
rassembleuse puisqu'elle n'a pas grand
chose à raconter
mathias auclair selon vous m'offrez la
transition sur le meeting de jean luc
mélenchon victime immersive plus de 3000
personnes images spectaculaires la forme
on peut on peut considérer que c'est
réussi je pense que tout le monde le dit
c'est vrai qu'il a renouvelé le genre
avec we sur la forme ça m'apparaît assez
réussie d'ailleurs les commentaires sont
plutôt élogieux aujourd'hui donc ça a
marché de ce point de vue là et sur le
fond je rejoins par ayant ce que dit
catherine tricot il ya un travail qui a
été fait par jean luc mélenchon ne
serait ce que parce que ils l'ont mais
ça ils l'ont met à sa troisième
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
donc il est avec marine le pen et que de
la répétition le plus ancien et le plus
expérimenté dans le poste je nuance
néanmoins l'explication par le déficit
de travail donc d'abord parce que on y
lit à jean luc mélenchon qui a travaillé
qui a peut-être encore plus travaillé
pour cette fois ci mais je note que dans
ce cas là le travail ne paye pas car il
est en deçà de là où il était il ya cinq
ans alors il est légèrement devant les
autres mais légèrement je sais que dans
le panel que nous on a la fondation qui
jean jaurès avec ipsos en réalité il est
au coude à coude avec jade ont donc il
est en recul significatif par rapport à
là où il était il ya cinq ans donc ça
compte et je dirais que le parallèle
qu'on peut faire avec la droite sur la
question du travail ne me paraît pas
opérant je ne suis pas sûr que la droite
est davantage travailler que la gauche
elle est quand même nettement moins bas
donc le déficit par le travail je nuance
l'argument la clé d'explication c'est
peut-être aussi de regard rétrospectif
sur les présidents pouvoir quand vous
interrogez en fait les électeurs de
droite ils disent au moins nicolas
sarkozy a fait quelque chose entre
2007 et 2012 il ya une forme de regret
et de nostalgie de nicolas sarkozy de la
part des électeurs dont et si bien qu'en
fait on peut voir aujourd'hui que tout
le monde à droite va se définir au se
revendiquer de nicolas sarkozy que même
d'autres comme marine le pen ou eric
zemmour vont pas attaquer pour revenir
sur le bilan de nicolas sarkozy donc à
cette forme de figure tutélaire qui
existent positivement pour la droite et
qui fait qu'on a quand même envie de la
part de cet électorat là de retrouver
cette forme de flamme sarkozyste qu'une
quitte à ce qu'elle soit incarnée par
valérie pécresse du côté de françois
loin de la gauche c'est quand même très
différentes à dire qu'en fait
aujourd'hui les électeurs de gauche sont
pas fiers d'avoir porté france hollande
à la présidence de la république qu'en
termes de valeur ou n'en parlais tout à
l'heure il y en a peu aujourd'hui qui
les amène à dire au moins à cette
période-là la gauche pouvait être fière
de ce qu'elle avait réalisé et puis il y
à ne plus pas vraiment de réalisations
concrètes à leurs yeux qui leur permet
de dire mis à part le match pour tout ce
qu'on arrive à faire la différence
concrète pense que peut être la gauche
ou la droite aux responsabilités et
notamment toute la question de la
gestion économique oncle âgé sous la
fiscalité ne constituent pas des points
sur lesquels aujourd'hui la gauche peut
s'appuyer en dix ans au moins si on
revient de mon pouvoir ça sera ça on se
sera différent moi ça sera mieux que ce
qui a été fait de la part de manuel
macro way est ce que ce meeting dray sur
la forme un réussi mathieu sous caire
est ce que ça peut relancer la campagne
de jean luc mélenchon est ce que vous
vous donnez encore beaucoup d'importance
à un meeting dans une campagne
meeting cc a marqué les esprits c'est ça
à mobiliser d'abord ses sympathisants ou
ses militants là pour le coup l'exercice
et réussit donc les militants sortent
d'une salle de meeting galvanisé c'est
quand même mieux que quand ils sortent
le moral dans les chaussettes et à
gauche m beaucoup de raison chez les
autres candidats de sortir le moral dans
les chaussettes
donc en plus on le sait jean luc
mélenchon c'est une bête de campagne on
aime on n'aime pas mais il sait faire
campagne il sait faire tourner le débat
autour de lui il sait galvaniser ses
troupes et il sait faire la différence
avec d'autres candidats parce que c'est
un tribun hors pair parce qu'il a le
passé qu'il a le phrasé qu'il a les
références historiques qu'il a et que
certains paraissent bien pâles à côté
problème juridique une chose c'est qu'il
ya toujours un petit peu de mal en fin
de campagne et connaît toujours un petit
coup de mou enfin tout cas c'était le
cas en 2012 ça a été le cas
en 2017 mais il ya toujours un moment où
une fois qu'on a rassemblé son camp il
faut quand même offrir aux autres des
perspectives de rassemblement et dans
cette phase là la veille du premier tour
il ya toujours un petit peu de mal parce
que ça c'est c'est un peu orthogonale
avec le discours qui est tenu pendant
pendant cette campagne de premier tour
moi j'ai l'impression que laïb a
bénéficé d'une chose c'est que c'est un
brouillard est tellement décevant à côté
de lui que finalement il apparaît comme
une butte témoin un repère quelque chose
qui tient debout quoi c'est à dire que
alors je pense qu'il a par ailleurs la
gestion de ces cinq dernières années qui
n'ont pas été très rassembleuse et qui
ont même été cliente au point qu'ils se
retrouvent avec un candidat communiste
face à lui ce qui n'était pas le cas en
2012 et en 2010 est donc il ya bien
quand même quelque chose qui dans sa
gestion un peu hégémoniques finalement
pas de rassemblement mais d'imposer son
point de vue reste de la gauche je pense
qu'il risque de le payer mais en même
temps dans ce marasme général il
apparaît comme celui qui tient maintient
un discours de gauche auquel la gauche
peut se reconnaître pense quand même que
la séquence parlons d'y revenir mais 2 2
de son siège voilà le lot d'une
perquisition ce que je cherchais merci
de m'aider ça abîme et durablement son
image sais pas comment vous vous
l'évaluez dans dans les intentions des
jades en terme d'image en termes de
confiance
avant que ce sera de vie d'un point de
vue des capitales électorale quand on
demandait aux français qu'en mai jugeant
les points chauds où il apparaissait
comme étant beaucoup plus agressive
beaucoup moins respectueux en fait de la
république d'un point de vue général et
qu'on a vu en fait il y avait une
acrimonie qui a été monté même de la
part d'une partie de son électorat me
sens pas si j'avais 10 ans 2 % de rythme
et on l'a compris quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui son positionnement en fait
il dit pas à voter pour moi il dit voter
pour mon programme politique et je ne
suis en fait entre guillemets que le
porteur d'un programme politique oui
mais n'empêche qu'ils s'effacent pas
totalement
enfin quand vous regardez en fait tout
ce qu'il a dit au cours de ces trois cas
d'année moi c'est vous allez voter pour
un programme politique il y aura une
constituante je ne suis d'aucune manière
transitoire jusque là que pour deux ans
pour éventuellement mettre en place les
choses mais je ne serai pas vraiment le
seul décisionnaire donc il ya aussi une
compréhension de sa part que peut-être
qu'une partie de son programme politique
est plus apprécié que ce qui peut être
personnellement ils sont faciles et
pardon de vous les 19 % et ainsi se
résume de manière à ils vont pas vous
dire que quand vous regardez aujourd'hui
on l'a vu d'ailleurs au cours des
dernières consultations électorales on a
un électorat de gauche et qui ne va pas
voter pour la droite qui va pas se
prolonger vers un autre candidat
d'extrême fait extrêmement de gauche
coxon vous fait entrer en tout cas qu a
tendance à rester chez lui à dire dans
ces circonstances là on n'y va pas et
face à une gauche qui est éclatée on a
du mal à voir ce procès ait de quoi
rester chez nous alors il ya une
séquence qui suscite pas mal de
critiques depuis hier séquences
extraites du du meeting du candidat de
la france insoumise ce moment où il fait
huer la vaccination on regardait
alors
maladie se propage
et alors ils inventent des passes
sanitaires et des vars a eu deux trois
quatre cinq d'or
chaque ferme et un seul élevage intensif
et sans faire cesser le martyre des
animaux est le danger pour les êtres
humains ou matthieu croissandeau quand
vous l'analysez cette séquence et il
faut la voir puis surgit du
développement où on peut contester
d'ailleurs que fait jean luc mélenchon
pour qui l'apparition de virus est aussi
une conséquence de la déforestation
enfin il lit environnement santé est
donc là et si la liste voilà il est
système capitaliste il a toujours eu un
positionnement assez ambigu sur le
vaccin vous le dire j'ai re il a quand
même commencé en disant qu' il n'avait
pas confiance dans les surgelés ou
souvenez que du vexin messages et les
airs il a refusé de dire s'il s'analyse
se faire vacciner ou non il prônait le
vaccin russe et non pas le vaccin
américains ou celui de 2,2 moderna donc
il a eu toujours cette position ambiguë
pour ne pas froisser cette frange de
l'électorat qui en veut à la politique
sanitaire du gouvernement au nom des
libertés publiques je dis pas qu'il ya
des complotistes ou des antilles vague
forcément chercher jean luc mélenchon il
ya une frange de l'électorat en tout cas
qui est vent debout contre ce qui est
considéré comme un rétrécissement des
libertés individuelles et des libertés
publiques d'ailleurs d2 et donc du coup
il joue l'ambiguïté là dessus mais là
dans son développement il faut quand
même leur mettre dans le contact c'est
vrai que la foule une oui
forcément je alesi terminera dans mes
choses qu'il souligne plus voilà la
mainmise de ces grands labels big pharma
d'un point de vue capitaliste sur sur la
gestion de la pandémie que sur le
bénéfice vaccinale au sens propre -
c'est comme ça que je ressorte ski même
si culte un étang minutes et matthieu
croissandeau fait ce qu'il sait que l'an
clair l'ambiguïté l'ambiguïté tactique
sur laquelle ambiguïté sur laquelle le
joug jean luc mélenchon depuis quelques
semaines sur ce sujet en fait et est
aujourd'hui techniquement risqué puisque
l'opinion française est elle même a
considérablement muté sur la question du
vaccin à la butée au même rythme que les
que le virus d'accord il ya un an 6 sur
le pas l'accident est la même
il ya une balance qui est en train de se
faire c'est derrière l'idée quand même
que peut-être le passé vaccinale c'est
un pas de trop si on parle si on parle
du pass vaccinale s'adresse oui mais on
a eu un début de son ancien nom mais en
un an quand même l'opinion française est
passée d'une opposition en tout cas une
hésitation vaccinale majoritaire a
aujourd'hui je voyais un sondage de
l'ifop qui disait que aux trois quarts
l'opinion française est aujourd'hui non
pas pour la vaccination mais pour
l'obligation vaccinale et ça vaut
quelles que soient les sympathie
partisane c'est beaucoup plus forts
évidemment à la république en marche
mais même chez les électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon je dirais même chez des
acteurs de marine le pen la majorité est
désormais acquise à l'obligation
vaccinale et deuxième dimension pardon
ça conduit à ce que les oppositions dans
leur ensemble appartient à travers le
débat qui se nouent depuis des semaines
et des semaines les oppositions dans
leur ensemble ne sont pas considérées
comme crédibles pour ce qui est de la
gestion de la crise sanitaire plus
crédible en tout cas que le pouvoir en
place y compris pas valérie pécresse
j'ai la proportion de français qui
considèrent qu'elle aurait fait moins
bien qu emmanuel macron est supérieure à
la propose la proportion de français qui
considèrent qu'elle aurait fait mieux
donc on voit bien que sur ce débat
sanitaire en tout cas les oppositions
n'ont pas réussi à se construire des
positions crédible et payante
électoralement alors je vous propose
maintenant de faire un focus un gros
plan sur cette primaire populaire
j'appelle aux rêves états à nous à nous
rejoindre bonsoy audrey bienvenue donc
on va déjà avec vous et puis ensuite on
rejoindra le porte parole de cette
primaire comprendre en quoi ça consiste
et puis peut-être aussi qu'il organise
alors c'est une primaire qui a été lancé
par des militants indépendants l'idée
germe depuis 2020 et le but c'est de
désigner un candidat commun pour la
gauche et les écologistes leur credo
c'est seul on va plus vite ensemble on
va à l'elysée et ya déjà eu une sorte de
pré sélection 130000 citoyen désigné
sept candidats potentiels et ce qui est
particulier c'est que ces candidats
n'ont pas forcément donné leur accord
certains ont été inscrits d'office alors
on retrouve dans la liste de ces sept
candidats jean luc mélenchon anne
hidalgo yannick jadot qui eux refusent
de reconnaître le résultat de cette
primaire on a aussi christiane taubira
vous en avait parlé pierre larrouturou
le fondateur de nouvelles donnes et puis
des personnalités peut-être un petit peu
moins connus charlotte marchandise c'est
une ex-adjointe rennaise la santé ou
encore anna haag apporterait elle est
militante écologiste alors comment ça va
se passer dans les prochains jours alors
le vote aura lieu en ligne du 27 au 30
janvier il est d'ailleurs encore
possible de s'inscrire gratuitement
jusqu'au 23 janvier minuit les
inscriptions d'école 1 250 mille
inscrits on était à peu près à 150
milles au début du mois c'est plus que
la primaire a l'air avec 150 mille
militants pas forcément inscrit mes
militants et plus aussi que la primaire
écologiste 120 mille inscrits le vote
aura lieu au jugement majoritaire qu'est
ce que c'est ça veut dire que chaque
votant va donner son avis va noter
chaque candidat très bien bien assez
bien passable insuffisant et ensuite on
fait la moyenne et le gagnante c'est
celui qui a obtenu le meilleur jugement
merci audrey pour toutes ces précisions
et j'accueille
donc samuel grzybowski qui est le porte
parole et cofondateur de cette primaire
populaire qui est avec nous en duplex en
visioconférence vous nous confirmez ce
chiffrement soir de 250 mille inscrits
et peut-être aussi est ce que ça veut
dire qu'ils deviendront forcément des
électeurs pour bien comprendre ce qu'ils
nient ce qui est en jeu
oui tout à fait je vous confirme que ce
mal par des communiqués par le fait
qu'on avait 250 inscrits inscrits sur la
plateforme de valve qui veut dire que tu
es permanente et un processus de vérité
on pète uriner adresse mail numéro de
téléphone et carte bleue est bon cela
veut dire que tu es personnes sont
prêtes à voter on pense qu'elles vont le
faire puisqu'on avait aussi avoir une
base de fiat air soutien qui avait
appelé être que ce vote ait lieu qu'ils
étaient trois familles ballon toulon
j'ai fait d'inviter tous les soutiens
militaires à devenir de vrais
est ce qu'elle est pas un toit en train
de vous échapper cette primaire
populaire est ce que le devient pas une
source supplémentaire de fractures à
gauche quand même
s'il ya une partie est très impopulaire
qui nous échappe c'était un peu le but
quand on a commenté il faut rappeler
l'origine fait devancer par des citoyens
vous l'avez dit indépendant des partis
mais surtout qui pour la plupart d'entre
eux ont battu le pavé pendant ce
quinquennat et même 2016 avec la loi
travail qui sont mobilisés dans les
combats féministes en terre a fini de
climat social gilet jaune et qui soit un
peu dégoûté de l'absence de victoire en
politique pour toutes les idées qui sont
fatigués de cette impuissance et qui
cherche en quelques sortes à changer a
redonné le goût de la victoire et donc
de ce désespoir l'a aidé en train d'être
un nouvel espoir alors elle peut
rajouter provisoirement à la confusion
mais trop pensé qu' à terme combatcamera
de la clarté parce que 85% des électeurs
de gauche le rassemblement soit défendre
contre elle de bonnes que cela passe par
un vote et donc ont proposé ou cette
opportunité simplement comme un sondage
grandeur nature c'est pas le cas mais
aurait fini comme un mouvement parce que
nous nous sommes engagés à soutenir la
personne qui va l'emporter
à la fin de janvier 1 5000 bénévoles 120
groupes locaux un prodige a beaucoup
marché 80 accompli de relever et bien
toute cette structure là bas de soutenir
le vainqueur avec alors la liaison n'est
pas très bonne en excuses auprès de nos
téléspectateurs mais vous l'avez sans
doute sûrement lu ça malgré vos skis le
juriste jean philippe derosier qui est
agrégé de droit public membre de
l'institut universitaire de france il
dit que votre prix mais elles étaient
illégales qu'elles s'apparentent un
sondage et c'est vrai que c'est audrey
l'expliqué l'instant c'est quand même
particulier d'inscrire quelqu'un contre
son dos
oui on comprend que ce soit à nouveau et
surprenant on s'est inspiré d'un
mouvement américain qui s'appelle le
sunrise haussmann qui a développé lui
aussi il ya quatre ans aux etats-unis
cette méthode d'investiture par les
citoyens pour peser sur le jeu électoral
tu des mouvements citoyens qui rentrent
en politique sans pour autant être des
partis avec cette logique que
l'investiture entraîne derrière une
campagne innovante on va chercher les
électeurs non-inscrits les autres
fonctionnalités dégoûter tous ceux qui
ont plus confiance dans les partis et
c'est sur la légalité du scrutin il n'y
a pas d'inquiétude à avoir on avait
publié ma réponse aujourd'hui dans le
jdd en réponse à m rozier paludisme
notre avocat maître bluteau qui certifie
non seulement que le processus est
parfaitement et les calmer en plus qu'il
ne s'agit pas d'un sondage puisque la
sondage me corresponde à deux
caractéristiques la première c'est qu'il
faut choisir l'échantillon orne où tout
le monde peut s'inscrire à condition
d'avoir seize noms et de reconnaître
l'esprit du socle commun et le deuxième
critère de sondages c'est qu'il faut un
panel représentatif
or il n'ya aucune représentativité dans
les personnes qui participent donc ce
n'est pas un sondage ça n'est pas une
primaire classique c'est vrai peut le
rappeler parce que les candidats ne sont
pas contraints de se retirer mais c'est
une aventure citoyenne pour faire
campagne aujourd'hui dur simplement pour
tous les électeurs perdus où vous l'avez
évoqué avant que j'arrive un sur deux ne
savent pas encore pour qui ils vont
voter on espère que cela va l'aider
alors restez avec nous parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire et c'est vrai
que ce système là c'est nouveau ça on
peut vous l'accordé mais ça pose quand
même un certain nombre de questions à
dire il ya un très bon a dit c'est la
réaction de christiane taubira c'était
samedi soir sur france 2 vous l'avez
peut-être vu quand laurent delahousse
lui demande ce qu'elle fera site ya un
cas d'école c'est jean luc mélenchon qui
arrive en tête de cette primaire
populaire la réaction de christiane
taubira si jean luc mélenchon par hasard
remporter cette primaire alors qu'il
n'est pas candidat cela veut dire que
vous ne serez pas candidat
à la primaire qui pourrait permettre
l'union de la gauche est une primaire
pour assurer le rassemblement donc c'est
à dire non ça n'est pas ça n'est pas un
dispositif de sujétion où d'humiliations
donc la personne qui sortira de cette
primaire est la personne qui symbolise
représente l'union de la gauche bon et
puis ça continue et manifestement enfin
voila c'est là pour moi c'est vraiment
symptomatique être un tricot on touche
du doigt les limites de de la
proposition oui face à dire qu'elle ne
se voir moi je penche en temps sa
réponse comme je suis la seule possible
je la seule légitime je suis la seule
qui incarne l'union de la gauche parce
que j'accepte le jeu de la primaire et
de jeu le poids politique parce que les
autres personnes dont personne n'imagine
que charlotte marchandises mais être
candidate de l'union de la gauche à
l'élection présidentielle donc donc ça
sera l après je veux dire en tout cas
c'est c'est comme ça qu'elle envisage de
changer je pense oui m'enfin le fera
quand même un vote et un vote ait jamais
écrit d'avancé ward et je suis d'accord
mais je suis d'accord sauf que non non
ce que je crois c'est que le fait que ce
soit un vote de cette nature c'est à
dire où chacun est jugé en plus ou moins
acceptable donne une prime à celui qui
est le plus consensuel le plus
rassembleur et or pour les raisons que
vous avez expliqué tout à l'heure je
pense que christiane taubira koch ces
cas c'est à dire qu' elle ne met une peu
de gens pensent qu'elle est absolument
super parce qu'on sait pas très bien ce
qu'elle pense mais par contre peu de
gens à gauche la déteste ne la supporte
pas voilà est donc dans ces deux ce
point de vue elle peut avoir
bien passable à peu près pour tout le
monde même quelqu'un qui aimerait qu'ils
voient très jean luc mélenchon il ya
probablement quand deux émettra
christiane taubira vous vous dites ça
peut être le plus petit dénominateur
commun de ceux qui vont s'exprimer lors
de cette primaire oui je pense qu'elle
va avoir ses soutiens et qu' elle
nourrit pippa les autres matthieu
croissandeau cette primaire c'est un
vraiment un ovni est un ovni intéressant
parce que s'est créée par des citoyens
de gauche qui va le faire l'union des
candidats et des partis malgré eux
puisque les partitions affiches de ce
fait d'accord les des citoyens de tente
de le faire aujourd'hui c'est devenu un
fait politique parce qu'elle va se tenir
ces primaires il y avoir deux cent
cinquante mille nouveaux tons et donc ça
va être interprété comme un booster pour
celui qui en sortir ou celle qui en
sortira gagnant après il ya une
interrogation peut-être qu'on peut on
peut on peut demander à monsieur
grzybowski le comment s'assurer une
primaire va lancer un parti qu'il
organise avec un corps électoral
délimité alors soit c'est que les
militants soient s'élançant de la
population en tout cas on sait comment
la s'assurer qu'ils ne va pas y voir une
prime à celui qui aura le plus mobilisé
ses soutiens on s'inscrire à cette
primaire on dit que chez les
mélenchonistes beaucoup de gens
s'inscrivent pas ce qu'ils aimeraient
bien voir jean luc mélenchon sortir au
jeu pas certain que christine taubira
peut-être qu'elles bénéficient de ce
plus petit dénominateur commun mais elle
a bénéficié de moins de troupes que
mobilisables que jean luc mélenchon ou
paie des socialistes s'ils venaient à se
mobiliser et ensuite quelles leçons
tirer de ça qu'est ce qui va se passer
au lendemain de cette primaire quelle
leçon et et jean luc mélenchon on le
sait il ira jusqu'au bout yannick jadot
on le sait lui il a déjà fait sa
primaire et je vais pas me taper une 2e
primaire j'irai jusqu'au bout anne
hidalgo après avoir dit j'en veux pas
puis j'en veux puis j'en veux pas c'est
la faute à jado au lendemain de de
résultats que va-t-il se passer si
jamais son score est très faible si elle
est largué par rapport à jean luc
mélenchon et yannick jadot et christiane
taubira peut-être que des voix monteront
au parti socialiste pour dire à quoi bon
voilà bref c'est un fait politique en
tout cas qui va structurer la campagne
et ce qui est étonnant c'est vrai que
c'est que ça vient d'aucun parti mais
d'une initiative citoyenne il ya un
point supplémentaire c'est que ça n'est
pas uniquement l'organisation d'un des
partages entre différents candidats
déclarés ou non déclarés c'est une plate
forme revendicative la forme
programmatique moon qui vient alimenter
en fait cette primaire populaire qui a
été réfléchi travaillé avec des
arguments et des points qui sont des
points qui peuvent être clivant même au
sein de la gauche donc qu'on peut même
avoir une forme de paradoxe à dire avoir
un programme politique et qu'ils ont été
définis dans le cadre de la primaire est
un candidat qui peut désigner dans le
cas de cette primaire et qui peut être
pour partie en désaccord avec les
centres d'orientation et sachant que je
suis pas persuadé d'ailleurs que les
citoyens aient conscience en fait
justement qui avait justement cette
forme de plateforme commune qui a été
établi et qui visait à faire en sorte
qu'il ya un minimum de principes de
regard à l'égard de la société c'est
assez fourni pour ce qui me manque le
teuton regarder et qui vont vraiment
défini ce que peut être des principales
orientations pour la france si jamais la
personne désignée dans le cas de la
première devait être le projet en la
prochaine présidente de la république
s'amalgament au ski il ya deux questions
d'abord effectivement ce que vous vous
demandez matthieu croissandeau sur le
voile à l'ailé l'organisation elle même
voilà les garanties que vous pouvez
donner et puis effectivement ce risque
finalement parce que ça ne fonctionne
que si c'est christiane taubira qui qui
sort en tête et qu'elle accepte le
les éléments de programmatique qui sont
proposés si tout autre cas de figure
divise encore plus et est fragile les
gauches
je suis pas sûr on peut voir ça plus
subtilement je pense que je peux
répondre à ces quatre éléments si vous
me permettez d'accord sur le premier du
soutien nous en tant qu'humain de
rassemblement pour la victoire ce qui me
nuls ces contrats la campagne de la
personne qu'il importe quoi qu'il arrive
et je crois qu'une série les premiers
mouvements unitaires à dire que par
exemple jean luc mélenchon je regarderai
ce rassemblement ce qui me permet de
vous dire très clairement ici que si
jean luc mélenchon encore tous les
tableaux france un camping avec les les
efforts dont nous disposons et moi je
vois le récit selon lequel anne hidalgo
l'emportent est bon qu'on dit on
retourne à la social-démocratie le ps
est 10 heures yannick jadot l'emportent
on dit l'écologie politique à la
nouvelle matrice jean luc mélenchon
changeant pas sorti les à 10 ou 13
points on lui donne les trois points qui
manquent pour gagner je vois tous ces
récits là sur la deuxième question de la
garantie dite
mais j'ai un peu l'impression que c'est
le cas là toutes les élections en plus
en mobilise plus on a de chances de
gagner nous la garantie comporte c'est
que tous les électeurs sont des vraies
personnes pourraient fuir il ya une
vérification du vote et qu'on utilise la
même plateforme numérique que celle qu'a
utilisée les républicains et les
écologistes c'est à dire avec nous et au
vote enfin un troisième élément sur
pourquoi est-ce que c'est par un parti
qui l'organisent je crois beaucoup
d'électeurs aujourd'hui ne reconnaissent
pas cette tripartition gros une espèce
de gauche entre les trois familles de la
social démocratie écologie politique et
la gauche radicale et comprennent en
fait est que sur tous ces trois familles
ont des points communs très fort face à
l'offre dé droite libérale identitaire
et conservatrice qu'il en tête ont créé
par miroir une sorte de d'unités naturel
chez nous gauche progressiste humanistes
ont refusé justement ces trois modèles
qui sont extrêmement mobiles en
utilisant le débat et enfin dernier
élément de réponse pardon d'être un peu
long sur le socle on a construit ce
socle commun avec deux vitesses camille
faut avoir en tête c'est à dix mesures
de rupture qui ont été co élaborés avec
les partis politiques dans le cadre de
débats en cinq semaines au mois d'avril
dernier et ses dix mesures de rupture
constituent les seules mesures que le
vainqueur devra mettre en elle
peut-être que vous évoquez aussi un
autre document qui est un rapport de
conversation beaucoup plus fournie dans
lequel il ya tous les débats et dans
lequel il
jurent qu'ils ne devront pas être mises
en oeuvre par la personne que nous
allons soutenir qu'ils sont juste là à
titre indicatif bon alors il nous reste
trois minutes dans ce débat je voulais
qu'on se projette un peu dans l'après
présidentielle législatives vont vous
savez quoi on va se garder ça pour un
autre débat on a encore presque trois
mois devant nous dans cette émission et
ce sera un débat intéressant parce que
j'aurai qu'on creuse et qu'on vous
entende de nouveau un peu sur cette
primaire populaire c'est dommage de ne
pas aller plus loin mathieu soutière est
ce que vous vous dites il ya un espoir
pour la gauche malgré tout avec cette
primaire populaire est ce qu'il faut pas
l'enterrer trop vite alors il faut pas
l'enterrer trop vite pour une bonne
raison on pensait en tout cas les ex
grands partis pensé qu'il pouvait se
passer de la primaire cette fois-ci dire
que les grandes consultations de 2017
qui avait abouti au désignation de
françois fillon et benoît hamon les deux
grands partis ont décidé de s'en passer
o les erp ont fait une primaire mais une
primaire fermée les seuls qui ont joué
le jeu en été ce sont des écolos qui ont
fait une primaire ouverte mais qui a peu
mobilisé là en fait la société civile
alors je dis pas que les 250000
personnes dont on parle aujourd'hui sont
représentatives de la société française
mais la société civile revient en fait
revient dans la campagne et comme le
disait mathieu tout à l'heure ça devient
un fait politique puisque même si on
sait pas très bien où tout ça nous mène
tous les candidats de gauche ont été
amenés à se positionner par rapport à
cette primaire soit pour dire j'y vais
et puis après j'y vais plus où j'irai
c'est sûr et giresse où je veux même pas
m'en occuper comme jean luc mélenchon
mais tous ont eu à se positionner par
rapport à cela ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à
ce stade oui ça entretient de la
confusion
non seulement ces entretiens de la
confusion parce qu'on ne sait pas sur
quoi ça débouche n'est par ailleurs ça
nous enferme dans le débat de la
désignation cette espèce de débat
totalement narcissique dans lequel la
gauche et du coup totalement aux
prisonniers depuis des semaines et des
semaines et on voit bien qu'elle peine à
sortir et tout ça pèse sur la qualité de
la campagne présidentielle
donc on a une gauche qui ne parle que
d'elle même alors même que pourtant la
question sociale et la question
environnementale sont tout en haut des
préoccupations des français et on a une
droite et une extrême droite qui
douteront sans maladresse son dérapage
en polémique orchestrée en fait nous
fait parler d'autre chose que d'un débat
de fond donc on devrait avoir à moins de
100 jours de la présidentielle un débat
de projet de société contre projet de
société et moins que même on en parle
moins que jamais je vais terminer avec
avec vous jean daniel lévy sur le la
volatilité de l'électorat rond mais moi
je dis quasiment tous les jours dans
cette émission c'est vraiment important
de le rappeler est ce qu'elle est encore
plus forte chez les électeurs de gauche
et rs qui a plu électeurs de gauche qui
ne savent pas pour qui ils vont voter
que des lecteurs des gauches aider oui
oui c'est plus fort et puis on est dans
un contexte où on a moins d'électeurs
qu'il envisage aujourd'hui de voter pour
la prochaine présidentielle qu'il ne
l'était il ya précisément 50 par rapport
à l'élection présidentielle de 2017 avec
un phénomène d'abstention qu'on a vues
de manière massive aux élections
municipales qu'on a vu renforcé aux
élections régionales et départementales
et où à nouveau alors même qu'on
considère en fait que la présidence de
la réplique c'est la mère de toutes les
batailles la clé de voûte des
institutions où il s'agit du moment on
peut tout le pays s'arrête pour pouvoir
vraiment c'est à dire à ce moment là en
partie et en général c'est le cas
aujourd'hui une forme de regard très
distant de la part des français à
l'égard de l'élection partielle
notamment autour d'une idée il n'y a à
l'heure actuelle aucun débat il n'y a
pas de confrontation n'y a pas de
conflit qualité et on a le sentiment que
ba globalement chacun raconte un peu son
histoire à son public gère son petit
fonds de commerce mais va pas chercher
forcément à conquérir l'ensemble de la
population française où une majorité de
la population française le fait qu'ils
aient ou non n'a rien fait j'ai quand
même il fallait dire tant que macro
n'est pas là je pense que c'est le top
départ de la campagne espace composé mon
goût en 1981 on peut reprendre 1988 2002
2012 il y avait aussi une situation où
des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle en tout cas sortant
n'était pas encore entré dans le débat
mais il y avait déjà une confrontation
merci beaucoup merci à tous vous avez
interrompu un peu un peu brutalement
tiens je je redonne catherine tricot le
dernier numéro de la revue regards le
voilà
la gauche grand remplacer et puis
mathieu le titre de votre livre
il est par la ce sur la flambée pour la
flore des populistes et c'est chez plon
merci encore à tous d'avoir participé
ici et en duplex à ceux à ce débat